[Musica]
[Applauso]
bentrovati e grazie per questo invito
partiamo da una cosa abbastanza banale
la curiera chi non l'ha presa almeno una
volta il bambino
davide la comincia a prendere quando sta
andando a como a studiare studiare poi è
una parola grossa
quindi a como a scuola sulla strada la
cosiddetta bassa la riva romantica la
strada quella che non è la panoramica ma
è quella che da cernobbio
arriva poi fino a brienno no quella che
passano tutti i paesi tipo l'aglio
karate e via dicendo
i ragazzi va dalla corriera vede un
palazzo che stanno costruendo che stanno
sistemando c'è anche lì un cambiamento
cambia qualcosa sulla riva e qualcuno
però non ha scritto viva juve o ti amo
coccinella non è che ha scritto queste
cose qualcuno ma con una pennellessa
proprio gigante su in cima usando
sicuramente i ponteggi dei muratori ha
scritto qualcosa che per tutto il tempo
finché andato all'intonaco è rimasto lì
una frase che mi ha urtato che mi ha
infastidito che mi ha smontato il
cervello è che ancora sono qui a
decodificare e che forse sto cominciando
a riuscirci
nostalgia del futuro
la prima volta che non ha cominciato a
dire canne ubriaco
l'adolescente che vuol fare il fenomeno
era diventata una specie di boomerang
tornava sempre questa frase nostalgia
del futuro è un controsenso è una
pirlata allora come posso scomporla come
posso io continuare con questa
ossessione arriva un punto in cui
cominciò a dire sicuramente noi abbiamo
avuto un'idea di futuro
sicuramente abbiamo proiettato in avanti
qualcosa che per noi doveva essere il
futuro ideale anche da bambini nel 2000
avremo le macchine che volano nel 2000
non ci saranno più questi problemi
nel 2010 poi chissà cosa faremo chissà
c'è un futuro che ci sta a cuore lo
abbiamo proiettato in avanti troppo in
avanti non è stato quello che poi
abbiamo incontrato e adesso come ha
scritto il pazzo
abbiamo a volte nostalgia di un futuro
che non c'è stato e che avrebbe potuto
esserci non riesco a concepire l'idea di
cambiamento come un allontanamento a
tutti i costi da ciò che è passato da
quello che noi chiamiamo il passato e
che poi alla fin dei conti non passa mai
del tutto come faccio io ad andare solo
avanti alla velocità con cui pretendo di
andare avanti senza controllare qualcosa
anche dietro ovvero la strada da cui io
provengo
come faccio a cercare in quello che
chiamo futuro
quella che dovrebbe essere una
perfezione che qualche volta noi abbiamo
assolutamente toccato e anche superato
nel passato con la semplicità con i
materiali primari con la genuinità con
la vita che era come l'abbiamo visto
prima la postura se è fisiologica se è
corretta
tu non hai dolore se la velocità per ora
non è corretta qualcosa succede e allora
mi sono fissato sul concetto di spaesati
gli spaesati quelli che chiamano i
paesani quelli che vivono e si ostinano
a fare ancora lavori antichi quelli che
non hanno accettato il cambiamento a
tutti i costi
ho scritto una canzone che non posso
cantarvi perché non è ancora stata
arrangiata con le canzoni quindi ve la
racconto perché oggi sembra proprio il
giorno giusto per raccontare un tipo di
canzone di questo tipo gli spaesati non
sono gli spaesati soltanto perché non
sono un po confusi sono spaesati perché
gli hanno tolto il paese quello che
c'era hanno nostalgia di quel futuro che
avrebbe potuto esserci ma che non c'è
stato
e io che ho viaggiato per tutti questi
anni attraverso le nostre valli le
nostre terre le nostre acque
ho fatto i conti con quello che ho
incontrato come un antropologo più che
un cantautore gli spaesati e in italiano
tranne un ritornello che dice femme quel
che fa quel che sembro fa se qualche sam
quel che se sembro st chissà in due una
renna fini ma seminiamo parti siamo
ancora qui a fare quello che ci hanno
detto che ormai è assurdo
siamo nati contromano
cresciuti controvento vivendo in
contropiede e sembriamo un controsenso
facciamo lavori vecchi con sogni
malpagati lavori da ostinati che tutti
credono svaniti siamo gli ultimi
brandelli di una bandiera vera che non
sai più se c'è ma che una volta c'era
capisce un la fatica in forze la formica
capisce un mea un progresso che sposta
la cadrega ci chiamano paesani ma siamo
gli spaesati i chiodi della storia ormai
arrugginiti abbiamo lunghe ombre e
ripariamo la memoria rimanere al nostro
posto è l'unica vittoria siamo stati gli
emigranti
siamo stati ritornanti vi abbiamo
riempito i libri credendoci ignoranti ci
hanno insegnato i trucchi per essere
moderni ci hanno fatto scrivere tutto e
poi buttare via i quaderni come fili
sottili di un mondo che si scuce siamo
l'urlo dello strappo che per adesso tace
sembriamo senza tempo sembriamo senza
pace ma chiamerete noi quando andrà via
la luce ci chiamano paesani ma siamo gli
spaesati
varchiamo dai confini soltanto
immaginati riconosciamo il nome del
posto in cui viviamo ma abbiamo perso il
codice per capire chi sanremo ci
chiamano paesani ma siamo gli spaesati
anche bloccati qui ci sentiamo
trasferiti siamo l'ultima frontiera tra
il ricordo e il cambiamento siamo il
popolo nascosto sorvegliamo un faro
spento
questa in dialetto un'altra storia
parallela il nonno e il nipote in nipote
magari ormai anche lui un manager hanno
venduto la terra giù nella pianura
ci sono tanti dubbi si intitola amy
imparare abbiamo ormai imparato nonu
camisa quadri vincerà denti in del
fazzoletto nono reggiana umbria dall
area da destra tour e il suo il par
quasi sport d'elite quel che capisco un
pil teme domande cos'è che pensi ma
pensi di domanda late nono contro piano
per beckham o la tua schiena dritta
no no senza paura de pizan altra
sigaretta da me a cuba i bombardamenti
da me occupa questa terra secca the coup
a me al catrame che te firmati ma quel
che ades quater alto pro am impara a
famiglia ton casotti qualche gi reni
stagioni è il sun che il tempo passa
ecco anche il passaggio sempre pressa
che cambierà la sua pelle come la
cambierà la bissa nono nel cambia mais
faranno un parcheggio da quattro piani
nono due ghiere tibesti venderanno i
surgelati
l'emea la prima volta che vedo un la
luna cambia la sua forma ma ogni volta
che l'asp harris che sembro paghi ora
che torna più in ray nonno
quante domande che seminiamo senza
concime nonno come vorrei dirti che è
giusto e che va tutto bene ma in tante
vardo nel tramonto fintan che riassuma
muove del penso che il tempo lascia come
thor e che poi me afferma è questo
[Applauso]
siamo partiti tutti per un viaggio dai
tempi in cui si facevano le cose fin
troppo semplicemente pitture rupestri
precise incisioni che sono rimaste fino
ad oggi quindi funzionavano
il metodo c'era non c'era la conoscenza
adesso ne abbiamo tanta non tutta non
raggiungeremo mai forse ma nel nostro
viaggio non possiamo cercare il domani
senza portarsi sulle spalle quello ieri
che ci interessa non rivogliamo indietro
la peste bubbonica non rivogliamo
indietro
l'olocausto piuttosto che le
persecuzioni ma le cose che funzionavano
vedete tutti che stanno tornando sono
tornate tante cose e sono state abbinate
a quello che chiamiamo il progresso il
progresso quello positivo quello buono
il cambiamento secondo me è il coraggio
di tornare a casa con quello che abbiamo
imparato a fare ea ed evitare e tornare
a prenderci in mano la terra quella che
avevamo tanto tempo fa all'origine
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]